this is not radar in Paris one of the
most famous sights in the city but I'm
not here for the view from the top or
for the flying buttresses or even for
religion I'm here for something just
outside if you look down from the top
and stand just outside the main entrance
you will find a marker on the floor
called point zero point zero is the
place from which all distances in France
are measured now I'm filming all the way
out here by the way because once one
person starts taking video of it it
starts to attract tourists in the same
way that artisanal French bread attract
pigeons that's a visual metaphor for you
that France isn't the only country with
a point zero a lot of countries in the
developed world have them there'll be a
marker or a monument somewhere in the
capital city that says this is where the
numbering starts from the UK though I
know we don't have one neither does the
US I mean the UK just have Charing Cross
in London but there only some roads are
measured from there and the u.s. well
you do have a marker in Washington DC
but well no one uses it for anything
most US states restart the numbering
when a road enters their territory and
here in Paris though you have a mark
that isn't really used anymore in these
days of GPS and satellites but what you
have is a relic of a past time a marker
that simply says this is where we
started from this is back when we had
all the triangulation and manual
calculations needed to actually map
something back when it was longhand this
is where it all began that's point zero
and that is something you might not have
known